boy I really opened the floodgates on
this one okay guys
answering the Q&A questions I'm gonna
say right now next time I hit 10,000
it's not gonna be a Q&A again it's gonna
have to do something else for some
reason I did not clock in my head that I
had twice as many subscribers as the
last time I did this I was probably
gonna get at least twice as many
questions I am gonna try and address all
of them in some fashion there were a lot
if I missed one that you asked I'm sorry
it wasn't personal I there are probably
some that I genuinely missed even the
ones that I kind of don't intend to
answer I am I
I did try and get them down so that I
can at least acknowledge them now last
time I did this you know I did you know
sort of graphics coming up with what the
question is so you could see it and all
that I'm probably not gonna do that this
time because I am way behind where I
wanted to be going into this weekend and
adding that in in the edit takes time so
you're probably gonna have to watch me
read these things off my phone so I'm
actually gonna have to break this up
into two parts but I don't have to I'm
choosing to break this into two parts so
I was able to break down the questions
that I got into four primary categories
personal questions general opinion
questions questions about the channel
and future plans for it and questions
about Doctor Who so I'm gonna break this
into two parts in with two sections each
that I do plan to put them both up today
but you know I I thought if I do this as
one this is gonna be crazy long let's
break it up a little bit so this one's
gonna be on the future plan and channel
questions and then the Doctor Who
questions I'm not gonna bounce back and
forth I'm just gonna run through the
segments so we're gonna start with the
future plants and channel questions and
these are not in any particular order so
first up for animation junkie have you
thought to check out the two Ultimate
Avengers movies these are animated films
done by Marvel I don't have
them on my docket I'm not gonna say
never but honestly the the Marvel
animated stuff never really looked very
good to me and I also don't really like
The Ultimates all that much not from
having read you know the the earlier
trades do you attend any Comic Cons or
hope to one day do a live panel at a con
this was a question a few people asked
in in one form or another I have gone to
a couple of cons but like just as an
attendee I've never had a booth I've
never been on our panel I'd be game to
be on a panel as soon as a con asks me
but I've I've I've step I've stuck very
local Vermont comic-con Boston comic-con
I might check out Granite comic-con in
New Hampshire this year but I stay
within within a fairly tight radius just
because I don't have the budget to say
go out to San Diego congratulations on
twenty thousand subscribers speaking of
subscribers why do you think they
subscribe I mean what makes your YouTube
channel different from the thousands
possibly millions of others you know
what your guess is as good as mine like
I I've been doing this a long time like
when I think about it it's like scary
yelling I've been doing this now so
you're asking me why do people subscribe
to me I don't really have an answer it's
like when people ask me hey what advice
you give to a new youtuber of like don't
ask me that it took me five years to
break a thousand subscribers I've been
surging lately and I don't know why but
if you're asking like things that I see
get mentioned in comments when people in
some way reference why they subscribe to
me two main things come up one is I do
Doctor Who content every week seem to be
a fair number of people who are
appreciative of that and are tuning in
mainly for that and fine with it and the
other thing that's come up lately
especially as I've kind of started to
dip into more I guess controversial or
sort of heavily loaded topics is people
seem to appreciate the even-handedness
with which I try and approach these
things because I do have a tendency to
even if I do have a firm
that I'm trying to make I do usually
understand why the other side is arguing
what they are and I and I do try and
acknowledge that I try I really try to
avoid finger waving people seem to agree
so that you appreciate that or at least
the people who choose to subscribe to me
do how do you have time to make so many
20 plus minute videos in a week
I don't sleep not as seriously at this
point it's just a practice I mentioned
already I've been doing this a while and
most of these videos you'll notice have
very few cuts some of them basically
aside from the intro bits and the
closing credits don't have any I've
gotten pretty good at figuring out ahead
of time what points I plan to hit and
then just rambling and keeping the the
thought string going until it all Peters
out and I run out of ideas and that
means that the Edit which is usually
what takes a lot it takes the most time
is pretty quick because I don't have to
do a lot of cutting and he plans on
coming to New Zealand at all because if
you do you have a fair few fans here who
would love to meet you hint hint you
know what if I could afford it I'd be
game for it I know you started with
scripted pieces but it soon moved into
just you doing the reviews did this
happen organically or did you no longer
like doing the scripted things what
happened to the lady and gentleman used
to film with and used to be on the logo
and when did Paul and Ryan emerge on the
scene okay so a couple of questions
there the the two folks who were the
other primary characters way back from
this channel started and started as
scripted shorts that's Nicole and Nathan
playing the characters of Kathy and Dave
Nicole moved actually to the Caribbean
of all places and Nathan is still around
but he is hard to get a hold of because
he barely use actually doesn't really
use social media at all anymore and he
rarely answers his texts I've tried to
get him on here like to heaven
round table or something he's just
really hurts a wrangle at this point
basically the only time I see him
anymore is he has a he has a booth at
the local farmers market because he's a
blacksmith as far as Ryan and Paul I met
them through the local community theater
and we just started geeking out
regularly because we share a lot of the
same interests and eventually I found
myself going you know this was at a
point where I was trying to figure out
ways to to get more content and more
people on the channel of thinking you
know we could totally just record some
of these conversations basically and
just throw that up and that's pretty
much what I did would you ever consider
doing book reviews I'm I wouldn't rule
it out but I don't read as nearly as
much as I used to because I don't have
the significant chunks of time to do it
I mean if I have you know a quote
unquote free hour and a day I can read a
couple chapters in a book that I haven't
picked up for weeks or a month and might
even have to backtrack a chapter or two
to remember what the heck is going on or
I could watch an episode of the T of a
TV show actually see the whole thing and
if it's something that I do reviews on I
can get a piece of content out of it so
book reviews and until there is a
significant shift in what it eats up my
time then probably not although I do
plan to do like why it's awesomes for
some of my favorite book series but like
book reviews as a regular thing I doubt
it
who wrote the council of geeks music
gentleman by the name of Andrew frapp
ear he was the husband of a woman who my
daughter's mother went to college with
and he not sure if he still is he was a
music teacher but he composed the the
theme and also if you go back to the
scripted shorts there's music used
that's that's meant to be ambient music
and a tournament fighting game he did
that for me too how many people you have
helping with these videos behind the
scenes well at this point it's really
just one as far as behind the scenes
guys I mean when I have other
collaborators you
see them on the screen and I've had
contributions like you know there's the
drawing logo and the music and but these
were you know done once and now I just
use them over and over as far as active
behind the scenes some people have
noticed I now have somebody doing my
thumbnails who is way better at it than
I am a gentleman by the name of Joel
Johnson and yeah he came to me offering
to do them and it's working out pretty
well so far I think have you ever
thought about doing Council of geeks as
beer a wild you seem to suggest you feel
more comfortable presenting that way I
think most of the people who would watch
the Q & A already know about this but
just in case I've mentioned in more than
a few videos at this point I do have a
fluid sense of gender and one of the
things you can that sort of has emerged
from that is I do have a completely
different youtube channel called viral
wild wild spelled wyl de where I do
present feminine and talk about issues
relating to gender fluidity and
cross-dressing so to address the
question you know have I ever thought
about hosting this channel in the the
full look that I do is Vera short answer
no because that's a lot of work like
that doing that doing that level of
makeup is anywhere from from a half hour
to an hour depending on what I decide to
do with it but also you know beyond that
I don't have an issue presenting this
way so it's not like I'm aching to
present like Vera and I'm holding that
back I'm totally cool with with this in
regards to the recent surgeons subs what
do you think about why you had that
surge as far as a reason might go see
funny thing I've gotten better using my
analytics I can tell you exactly what
the most recent so not even most reason
biggest surge of ever had was the
queerbaiting video that I did last month
in May so like for frame of reference
analytics can tell me the number of
people who click the subscribe button
from a specific video and obviously
there are people who may still have
subscribed to me because of that video
they did it from the channel page or
something else but it's a pretty good
indicator so like for point of reference
the the second channel awesome video
that I did which was a decent spike
certainly by my standards that had about
300 people subscribe off that off that
page itself the queerbaiting video had
over two thousand so when i look at the
fact that i have surged as much as i
have in the last month i know exactly
why that is why do you always wear the
hat your hair is awesome yes oh there we
go you know what will digit for the
remainder of this it's it's a it's a Q&A
you folks can handle it um so the the
hat the hell was originally something
that I started using regular regularly
because there were just days that my
hair looked like crap like there was a
point at which I I didn't know what to
do with it but I was just growing it out
while I was twiddling my thumbs trying
to figure out what to do we just started
to look like a shaggy mess and throwing
the Hat on meant not having to deal with
it or worry about how it looked that
started to become a consistent look and
then when I got a more you know
gender-neutral hairstyle and then
eventually you know grew it out and got
it died prior to effectively coming out
my last Q&A video back in January I
wasn't sure that this was something I
was going to be comfortable presenting
as on this channel at this point
obviously I I don't mind though I still
use the hat though for two reasons one I
worry that presenting like this in a
more you know sort of with my more
feminine aspects on display can be
distracting because you know this side
of myself is not is not often relevant
when it is relevant I'll ditch the Hat
you've probably noticed in some of the
videos but there's also a completely
logistical end of that do which is you
know I shelled out money for the logo
and the logo has the Hat so it's kind of
become a branding thing at this point
and I don't want to I don't want to pay
to get the logo
designed so III I don't want to say I'm
obligated and now locked into that look
if like if it starts to bother me I'll
ditch the Hat but yeah I I that's why
it's still there
okay so last thing on Don this topic
before you move on to Doctor Who stuff
and this is just a quick list of
basically will you review things because
basically there were a lot of people
that asked you know will you talk about
this this any interest in discussing
this and I'm just gonna burn through
these pretty quick
Sonic the Hedgehog know it's not
something I have any nostalgia for and
it's not something that I would have a
reason to get into now could you rank
the Harry Potter movies maybe at some
point it's not a my to do list at the
moment though the Merlin TV series never
saw it not planning to the Lucifer TV
series I saw three episodes I did not
care for it so probably not the Planet
of the Apes series I'm going to assume
that whoever asked this means like the
classic Planet of the Apes series since
I do have reviews of at least the second
two of the reboot franchise maybe
because I actually have seen all those
and I do have an affection for that
series but not currently planning to and
I think scooby-doo related well I did do
the Scooby Doo and Batman Brave and the
bold team-up aside from that probably
not
scooby-doo also not something that I was
ever all that much into I was a little
more into it than into Sonic because I
did actually you know watch Scooby Doo a
little bit but no probably not the
eighties Legend of Zelda cartoon nope
didn't watch it don't have an interest
can you make a video ranking every Star
Wars film yes that in fact is on the
docket and is gonna come out and I'm not
gonna say exactly one cuz I have to keep
reshift in the schedule a stuff happens
but in the not so distant future peaky
blinders they haven't seen it no idea if
I'll ever talk about that the Super
Mario Brothers movie maybe because it's
kind of a fascinating oddity but not
currently planned so now we get into the
monstrous amount of Doctor Who related
questions I'm gonna try and pick up the
pace on this cuz there's a lot of these
out
new who what is your favorite
regeneration I think my favorite
regeneration at so far was Smith -
Capaldi and when I say that I mean the
regeneration moment itself because I
actually don't really like time with the
doctor as an episode very much at all
but I do really like the the suddenness
of that regeneration I like Matt Smith's
line leading up to it I do like the the
raggedy man moment that he has with Amy
so I think is that's probably that's
probably it if you can you do doctor who
reviews list etc more often for my own
sanity probably not right now it is a
weekly feature it is every single Sunday
I don't want to do it any more often
than that for a couple reasons one its
it would squeeze out other stuff and I
like talking about a lot of other stuff
but beyond that I loved r2 and I don't
ever want to burn out on it and I fear
that if I if I did it
Doctor Who stuff more more frequently if
I did it like twice a week I'm just
really worried that I would start to
tire of my favorite thing and I don't
want to do that on a scale of one to ten
one being hell-bent and ten being with
dr. Dan says what what do you rate
loving monsters on that scale of three
is there any episode of Doctor Who you
wish you hadn't seen not really like
even the ones I've hated I haven't been
like man I wish I hadn't watched that
even hell-bent of all things I'm so glad
I saw because I think it's helpful to
see at least once how badly things can
get so you can appreciate when they
actually work do you think doctor who
could use another ten year hiatus and
then continue canonically from there I
don't think it's necessary for that to
happen but I don't think it would be the
worst thing ever a lot of doctors have a
lot of similarities with other doctors
in my opinion Peter Capaldi a lot of
similarities with Tennant really which
previous doctor do you think Jodie
Whittaker will be most likely
like at a random guess I'd say Tom Baker
but I've got nothing to base that off of
with the debut of Jodi Whitaker's the
thirteenth doctor drawing ever closer
I'm curious as to which actors or
actresses you would like to see take on
the role in the future I actually have a
long time have wanted Patterson Joseph
to get the part I think he would be
awesome I base that largely off his role
as the the Marquis de Carabas and never
where he's amazing in that I'm failing
that and I know this person would never
get cast because they do movies and it
would be too expensive but Tilda Swinton
unpopular Doctor Who opinion I don't
know I don't think I think anything
that's that excessively controversial I
suppose it seems to be my thoughts on
the Tenth Doctor ie my belief that he is
too human and his behaviors and the fact
that he keeps slipping further and
further down every time I do a rear ank
of of the doctors that seems to be the
one that I get pushed back on the most
these days so I know doctor who has only
done a handful of animated projects five
that I can think of off the top of my
head but I was wondering if what your
thoughts were on those I've seen three
of those and they're fine I don't ever
need to see them again
I might talk about scream of the shock
at one point because it is kind of a
really fascinating oddity of a project
but yeah they're just kind of there
you say Heaven Sent might be your
favorite Doctor Who episode so which is
your favorite
I really hate answering that because
there's a reason I've never done a
top-ten Doctor Who episodes of all time
I always bring it down into categories
you know top 10 for each doctor top 10
written by certain write or etc but if
you're gonna pin me to a wall on it I
would say city of death what was your
opinion of the Matt Smith cameo in deep
breath I thought it was fine I kind of
liked it even although I get why it
annoyed some people which is your
favorite writer or writers if you feel
like naming a few for Doctor Who main
show and in audio well to date the ones
that I will put on their will
Rob Sherman Jamie Matheson Steven Moffat
yes even though he wrote hell bent he's
also written some stuff that I really
love Robert Holmes and I suppose we have
to put Terry nation just on a
grandfather clause do you think overall
doctor who has done a good job with
addressing the LGBTQ community I yeah
for the most part I think they have I
think it's been one of the better shows
overall in terms of that kind of
representation and addressing of things
when you saw the episode the Satan pit
during your honeymoon in London and you
stopped on an ood did you stop on the
scene where the Beast was speaking to
the doctor I've told this story in the
past it was how I first how Doctor Who
first really came on to my radar was
channel surfing on my honeymoon and
seeing a nude and going oh no it wasn't
that scene it was it was this it was
where they're like crawling through the
vents to get away from the you'd that
was when I first came in on that episode
if you were the showrunner for Doctor
Who how long would you get rid of the
Daleks two years have them come back on
a Christmas special what's your opinion
on the Eighth Doctor adventures with
Lucy can't tell you because I haven't
gotten to them yet most underrated
Doctor Who episode in your opinion this
is actually hard for me because I don't
have all that many that I would call
underrated there are ones that I call
over hated ie they're not good but
they're not like as bad as I think a lot
of fans tell them but only one I get
really like really people hate that one
is let's kill Hitler I enjoy it and
again I'm not like saying it's a
misunderstood masterpiece or something
but I seen it show up on worst list and
I always kind of scratch my head at that
worse Doctor Who episode you've seen
hell-bent what direction would you like
the new doctor to go in and how much of
a difference do you actually think
having a woman will make well if I have
my way it would make as little
difference as possible I want as little
emphasis put on as possible I want as
few references to it as possible I want
things to move forward with whatever
personality Jodie Whittaker intends to
infuse the doctor with when there is no
Doctor Who content to review like now
why not do reviews for spin-offs like
the Sarah Jane Adventures or Torchwood
well if I ever completely catch up on
classic who I might do that but the
thing is like I mentioned I don't want
to do more than one doctor who related
thing a week unless like news is broken
and then you know I'll stick something
in the middle of the week but I I would
rather get through classic and work on
deepening my knowledge of Big Finish
before I would care to rewatch either of
those shows if you could choose who
would you pick to play the next master
or mistress Eddie Izzard I'm dead
serious what do you think of
cliffhangers happening at the ending of
a season finale I don't hate them but I
also don't love them they I'm just kind
of tired of them as a trump-like do they
really think we're not gonna tune in the
next series if they don't leave
something in a weird contrived
cliffhanger scenario I don't know do you
think doctor who will be cancelled after
series 11 no I do not
which doctor have you seen the least of
that would be the first doctor so far
are there any companions you would like
to see return to Doctor Who yeah there's
two there's ace and Wilf could the
doctor regenerate as a new form besides
a human being or a child if you think
yes could it work well I think it's
possible I mean they they have a point
of reference Romano's regeneration gives
us some wiggle room on that eye so you
probably could I think be a real bad
idea though least favorite moment from
all 12 doctors you know this is liable
to be a video topic somewhere down the
line so I'm gonna take a rain check on
that what does your daughter think of
Doctor Who who who is her favorite
doctor she she doesn't watch Doctor Who
I've learned the hard way I cannot
impose my fandoms on to her we we've got
a bit of overlap we've loved some of the
same movies but she does not share my
geek tons and I have come to terms with
that if we had one of the actors who
played the doctor play the master
instead which actor do you think could
give us an interesting performance you
would like to see and
is an interesting question I did think
about a for bet I would go with Peter
Capaldi I think he'd be a very cool
master who is your favorite individual
Dalek I just like the big red bellowing
leader ones that we tend to get which
doctor would you most like to travel
with in which TARDIS this is not the
same as my favorite to watch but if I
was gonna travel with the doctor I'd
want to go with the eleventh Doctor in
the eighth doctors TARDIS other than the
revival what shows do you think are the
closest descendants of old Doctor Who in
terms of style and format I honestly
don't know nothing that I watch do you
what do you think of subscribers who
only watch your Doctor Who related
videos um thanks for your patience and
sticking around for all the other stuff
they put out during the week if you
could write a Doctor Who story with the
return of Omega how would you do it I
don't I don't really know because I
really try to avoid sort of the the
fanfic II thing even as that even as a
mental exercise because I don't want to
lock into how like falling in love with
my own idea and then getting upset when
something else happens instead so I
don't really have an answer do you feel
the 13th Doctor sexuality should be
talked about next series if so how no I
don't and like because you said
sexuality I'm going to take you at your
word because sexuality is not the same
as gender identity so like I'm assuming
you mean like the whole question of well
now that the doctors a woman does that
make her a lesbian and my immediate
thought is a who cares I don't want to
see the doctor getting into a
relationship with anybody regardless and
beyond that if the gender swap thing is
not completely atypical on Gallifrey
which it seems to be leaning towards
it's not one would think that they don't
really get hung up on those labels in
the first place what do you think it is
that the new era of Doctor Who manages
to portray and do best compared to the
classic era because I did kind of rag on
knew who a bit when I when I did my
comparison video um well there's a few
things I mean the big things the
production values I know part of that's
time but I think even like of the time
this is a higher-caliber of the time is
going on then classic who was for the
most part musics a heck of a lot better
but if you mean in terms of like the
narrative I actually do appreciate
having the 45-minute closed-off episodes
because when they work they are really
wonderful and I do enjoy really tightly
done complete stories so we don't always
get gold with the 45-minute per show
format but when we do I really really
enjoy it and and it becomes like oh it
satisfies in an instantaneous
gratification kind of way that the
original show didn't do if you could get
rid of the overuse of the mystery boxes
in Doctor Who or the use of the same
kind of companion over and over again
which would you get rid of between those
two I get rid of the mystery boxes
because you know as much as I am sick of
the companion template of young
contemporary London attractive female I
as long as the characters well-written
bomb performed has good chemistry with
the doctor eventually I won't care
mystery boxes I'm so sick of at this
point would you ever want to see Captain
Jack Harkness come back sure I know
there are plenty of people who are like
really dedicated to that idea they are
craving his return I'm not there but I'd
be happy if he came back
are you avoiding spoilers for Doctor Who
series 11 if not then are you going to
talk about all the suppose at least
coming in I'm not gonna talk about them
because I am avoiding leaks like the
friggin plague you can pick one Doctor
Who companion who could defeat Thanos
who would it be
and why would it be ace I see what you
did there do you prefer the 8th or 2nd
doctor apparently this questioner
compared those two because they consider
them to be the most underrated between
those two I'm gonna go second what is
your favorite story for each doctor
classic and modern I'm not going to
explain these I'm just going to burn
through them first doctor Dalek invasion
of Earth second doctor tombs of the
Cybermen third doctor the time warrior
fourth doctor city of death fifth doctor
caves of Androzani sixth doctor the Holy
Terror that's a big finish audio I
haven't found
show story from him but I actually like
seventh doctor remembrance of the Daleks
8th doctor night of the doctor ninth
doctor the empty child two-parter tenth
doctor signs the library to Potter who
parter the eleventh Doctor the eleventh
hour and the twelfth doctor heaven-sent
and finally main things you would do if
you had complete control of Doctor Who
okay I had to write these down because I
thought about them so III have notes so
forgive me on this and this is the this
is the last one so are for this this
part of the Q&A companion from another
time I would prefer from the past but
just not from modern London
I need a break no more than three
stories set on earth per series you can
have your earth story to establish the
companion but I do not want to keep
coming back to this planet over and over
and over and over again bring in
Frobisher for at least one story and
make him Canon in the show google him if
you don't know what his deal is I
already mentioned no more Daleks for at
least two years
bring back ace for one story in a proper
send-off stay away from Gallifrey and
finally the doctor no longer regenerates
and Christmas specials the doctor will
regenerate at the series finale of
whatever is their last series and the
Christmas special serves as the first
adventure of the new doctor that's it
for this part of the Q&A stick around
later today I'll cover the the personal
questions and the general opinions stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]